bags and bags of food being thrown away
because the migrants don't want to eat
them
and they just go away this is all food
that is going to waste this is insane
this is fresh this is good food
good food but they don't want to eat it
they said they don't like it now what
you just saw is this huge amount of food
that's been thrown away daily at this
big New York City hotel that's been used
to house illegal immigrants now
according to this whistleblower more
than 36 400 have come to New York City
in the last few months and City
officials have put them up in at least
14 hotels one of them being the row in
Times Square now that's where the
pictures that you're seeing right now
were taken my next guest Felipe
Rodriguez says that he's worked there
since 2017 but now that illegals have
taken it over the place is complete
chaos and Felipe joins me now Felipe
good to see you tonight now when you say
chaos tell us what you mean fights drugs
altercations other violations
um good evening nice for you to have me
thank you
um
the the chaos uh that we see at the row
today
uh is compiled by uh
migrants being drunk uh drinking all day
smoking marijuana consuming drugs and
domestic violence uh people having sex
in the stairs young people teenagers uh
they use the stair the fire exit stairs
to to go in there and and do what we may
just do uh uh we have people you know uh
actually uh
trying to
act like the hotel is theirs and we have
no right uh the
the form in which they keep their rooms
is
horrendous they they don't they don't
clean it they don't fold their clothes
they don't I mean it's in piles and
piles uh they're hoarding clothes
they're hoarding whatever they can hoard
and there's no accountability and when
you go into our rooms and you say
something you know um
the the hotel uh management uh
especially uh the GM has directed us
that we're not allowed to to tell them
nothing and
practically they have Carl Blanche uh at
the route so Felipe Felipe so you're
what you'd say that is that you don't
see this sort of expected
gratitude for free housing
free food obviously shelter in a city
where rent is very expensive you're not
seeing a lot of that
when
there was a there was a time in 2017
where where I paid a lot of money to
to house my wife and my kids and I paid
cable I paid gas I paid light I paid uh
my car payments I there was a lot of
stuff that I had to be responsible for
uh fortunately for the migrants they
they got the government of the United
States to hand them carte blanche to
pretty much do as they as they wish they
go in and out of the hotel I will
um
you got people sick in there they're
spreading all type of illnesses chicken
pox uh covid uh or you may have
um and
and nobody is telling them they can't do
that uh so right now the ones that God
all the power the migrants the the hotel
workers lost their power of the hotel we
I mean the GM
it doesn't have our back he I guess all
he cares about is uh making the money
that he's making but well I don't want
to turn this into a personal grievance
about the GM or how the hotel is run
what we're interested in Felipe is
what's happening with the use of
taxpayer dollars New York it's estimated
has spent about a billion dollars that's
the estimate on the illegal immigrants
in New York City including the housing
that you're seeing now we show we're
showing picture pictures of weed
marijuana that you said was found at the
hotel
so how did you find it oh you didn't
find it do you know who this belong who
who this belonged to
I collected it
um
de marijuana was there was a fight in
the lobby I was there that night and uh
one of the migrants was drunk and he
took a swallow on the security officer
hit him in the head and the security for
the hotel took him down the NYPD
responded and when their NYPD entered
the hotel
the there was a couple of Teenagers by
the stairs of the lobby to go into the
top Lobby and um when they seen the cops
they just dropped the weed on the stairs
and I seen it so I took pictures of it
and I collected it and gave it to
security well Felipe this if if
all Americans could see what you've
witnessed
just in the last few months at this
hotel
in one sentence what do you think they'd
say
it's a disgrace
well that sums it up yeah Felicia
you've done more to illuminate this
situation than frankly a lot of folks in
the media because you had inside access
and we really appreciate your speaking
out and giving us this information thank
you very much hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else